Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. In 1637, 17 years after the landing of the Pilgrim Fathers in the New World, a force of the colonists joined with native allies to launch a devastating attack against a Native American tribe called the Pequots. 400 of the Pequots were wiped out. Men, women, children left dead amid the blazing of their wigwams. It was a fearful sight to see them thus frying in the fire, wrote a contemporary witness. And the streams of blood quenching the same and horrible was the stink and scent thereof. And that the tone of that reflects a sense of horror that was bred of a
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们广受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。1637年，即清教徒先父们在新世界登陆17年后，殖民者武装与其本土盟友联合起来，对一个名为佩科特的美洲印第安人部落发动了一场毁灭性的袭击。400名佩科特人被赶尽杀绝。男人、妇女和儿童倒在他们燃烧着的维格沃姆式茅屋之中。“看到他们这样在火中煎熬，真是一幕可怕的景象，”一位当代目击者写道，“随之而来的是滚滚血流，空气中弥漫着可怕的恶臭与气味。”这种语气反映出一种恐惧感，这种恐惧源于清教徒及其美洲印第安盟友所犯下的血案，
deeply Christian anxiety about the bloodshed that had been committed by the Puritans together with their Native American allies. But at the same time, even as some of the Pilgrim Fathers were expressing their sense of shock, there were others who were answering with the claim that God licensed slaughter in defense of Israel. Sometimes the scripture declare if the women and children must perish with their parents, one of the settlers said. We had sufficient light from the word of God for our proceedings. So, Dominic, that kind of brilliantly, right at the kind of the wellsprings of American history, it kind of sums up this sense of ambivalence,
以及他们内心深处对流血事件的基督教焦虑。但与此同时，就在一些清教徒先父们表达震惊之感的同时，另一些人则回应称，上帝为了保卫以色列，授权了这场屠杀。其中一位定居者说：“圣经有时表明，妇女和儿童必须与他们的父母一同灭亡。我们从上帝的话语中得到了充足的指引来开展我们的行动。”所以，多米尼克，这真是太巧妙了，就在美国历史的源头，它完美总结了这种矛盾心理，
of tension in the American view towards war, towards relations with other peoples. And it's a deeply rich theme, isn't it? I know you're very interested. It's a great theme, Tom. First of all, I'll say for regular listeners to to this podcast those of you who are playing a drinking game based on how often tom says deeply christian you are already one drink down so congratulations and there's going to be a lot of that there's going to be a lot of that i think today because you came up you came up with the idea of this i did i did not my choice so i'll tell you why i
以及美国人对战争、对与其他民族关系的观点中所包含的紧张感。这是一个极其丰富的主题，不是吗？我知道你对此非常感兴趣。这是一个极好的主题，汤姆。首先我要对本播客的忠实听众说，那些根据汤姆说“深深的基督教”的频率来玩喝酒游戏的听众，你们已经喝了一杯了，所以恭喜你们。接下来还会有很多这样的内容，今天估计会有很多，因为这个主意是你提出来的，我可没提，这不是我的选择，所以我来告诉你原因。
came up with it because i think um for europe like us and Britons like us, Tom, the religiosity of American political rhetoric is fascinating because it's so unusual in a sort of 21st century European context. And we've, of course, lived through a succession of United States wars, as famously the War on Terror, which George W. Bush accidentally, in an apparent slip of the tongue, described as a crusade. And the subject of, you know, people have attacked the Americans as crusaders. And we had, some months ago on this podcast, Professor Andrew Preston from Cambridge, who came on and talked brilliantly about Vietnam.
我之所以提出这个话题，是因为我认为，对我们这样的欧洲人和像我们这样的英国人来说，汤姆，美国政治修辞中的宗教色彩是令人着迷的，因为它在21世纪的欧洲语境下是如此罕见。当然，我们也经历了一连串的美国战争，最著名的就是小布希在口误中无意间将反恐战争描述为一场十字军东征。而关于人们指责美国人是十字军的主题，几个月前，我们在这个播客里请到了剑桥大学的安德鲁·普雷斯顿教授，他来这里给我们作了关于越南的精彩演讲。
And when I knew him years ago he was embarked on this massive research project that basically took him to every tiny you know theological seminary in midwest of the United States about the interface between religion and war in American history and his book's called the sword sword of the spirit shield of faith so he's a top historian of American religion and foreign policy. But interestingly, he's also a top Canadian. So he's kind of got a slight... Midway, yes, between Britain and America.
多年前我认识他时，他正致力于一项庞大的研究项目，这基本上把他带到了美国中西部的每一个微不足道的、你知道的宗教神学院，研究美国历史中宗教与战争的交汇点，他的书名叫《圣灵之剑，信仰之盾》，所以他是研究美国宗教和外交政策的顶尖历史学家。但有趣的是，他也是一个顶尖的加拿大人。所以他有点……处于英国和美国之间的一个折中点，是的。
Exactly. So he's the perfect person to be talking to. And have you sourced him for us? Sourced him? Yeah, he's right here now, Tom. Andrew, welcome. Welcome. Thanks so much for joining us.
没错。所以他是谈论这个话题的完美人选。你给我们请来他了吗？请来了吗？是的，他现在就在这儿，汤姆。安德鲁，欢迎欢迎。非常感谢你加入我们。
I'm absolutely delighted that we're going to be talking about this theme. And I didn't suggest it. Well, welcome. Thanks so much for joining us. I'm absolutely delighted that we're going to be talking about this theme and I didn't suggest it. Well, okay. So I realise I'm not going to get much of a word in edgeways between the two of you in this podcast, but go ahead, Tom, have the first question. So Andrew, would it be legitimate to say that the American way of war, the American way of diplomacy, that you can trace it back to the Pilgrim Fathers, to the beginnings of New England? I think there's certain ideas that you can trace back. to the Pilgrim Fathers, to the beginnings of New England? I think there are certain ideas that you can trace back. They disappear for a while,
我非常高兴我们能讨论这个主题。而且这不是我提议的。好吧，欢迎。非常感谢你加入我们。我非常高兴我们能讨论这个主题，而且这不是我提议的。好吧，好吧。所以，我意识到在这期播客里，我很难在你们两个之间插话，但没关系，汤姆，你来问第一个问题吧。那么，安德鲁，如果我们说美国的战争方式、美国的外交方式，可以追溯到清教徒先父们，追溯到新英格兰的开端，这是否合理？我认为有些思想确实可以追溯到清教徒先父们，追溯到新英格兰的开端？我认为确实有一些思想是可以追溯到那里的。它们消失了一段时间，
and then they're revived at various points. But the ideas were certainly there in the early 17th century, partly from the Pilgrims, but also from the Puritans who come over in 1630, John Winthrop and his great fleet, where he says, the eyes of the world are upon us. And he tries to set up an example for, um, Americans to follow. I mean, historians since have said he wasn't actually
然后在不同的历史节点又再度复兴。但这些思想在17世纪初期确实已经存在了，部分源于清教徒先父，但也源于1630年漂洋过海来到这里的清教徒，即约翰·温思罗普和他庞大的船队，当时他说，世界的目光都聚焦在我们身上。他试图为美国人树立一个效仿的榜样。我的意思是，后来的历史学家们说，他其实并不是打算代表未来永世、代表这个伟大的超级大国，直到四百年后依然如此；
intending to speak for time immemorial for this great superpower for, you know, 400 years later. Um, but just, he was sort of invoking just standard Puritan doctrine about being special and being, you know, they have a providential mission and whatnot. Um, uh, but then that that that idea of the u.s being a city on a hill with the eyes of the world upon them um becomes really embedded in american political culture so so that kind of speaks to a couple of questions we got from our listeners um on our discord channel so liam boyd asked how we're defining american crusades and mark woodhouse said basically hasn't religion isn't everybody's aren't everybody's wars um informed by their
嗯，他只是在引用一种标准的清教徒教义，关于自身的特殊性，关于他们肩负着神圣的使命等等。嗯，但是后来，“美国是山巅之城，世界的目光都聚焦于此”这种思想，真正深深植根于美国的政治文化之中。所以，这某种程度上回应了我们在Discord频道上收到的听众提问——利亚姆·博伊德询问我们如何定义美国的十字军东征，而马克·伍德豪斯则说，基本上，难道宗教不是……难道不是所有人的战争都受到其宗教信仰的影响吗？为什么美国有什么不同？我想这就是那个价值六千亿——实际上是六十亿美元的终极问题，安德鲁。美国真的有什么不同吗？它的战争也是如此吗？如果是的话，那是因为清教徒的传承吗？好吧，听着，对于你们的听众来说，我可不写你们提前准备好的宣传词，所以我并不是在宣称美国是绝对独一无二的。我不知道他在瞎扯什么，他确实写了……
religious faith why is america any different and i suppose that's the the the six thousand million six billion actually six billion dollar question um andrew is america different are its wars and and if so is that because of that puritan heritage well listen for your for your listeners i mean i don't write the publicity that you guys come up with ahead of time so i'm not claiming that the u.s is completely unique i don't know what he's lying he does write the people uh but no i certainly wouldn't claim that americans are absolutely unique in this and nobody else has been informed by religion or their their their ways of waging war the reasons for waging war I certainly wouldn't do it on a podcast with one of the hosts here who's written a lot on that in other societies and other periods of time.
不过说真的，我当然不会宣称美国人在这一点上是绝对独一无二的，也没有人会说别人的宗教信仰没有影响他们的战争方式或发动战争的理由。我当然不会在一个有某位主持人在场的播客里这么说，这位主持人在其他社会和历史时期曾就此撰写过大量著作。我认为在现代，美国可能并非独一无二，但在宗教成为塑造美国人为何发动战争、如何进行外交、如何在世界上行事的因素的一致性上，它对大国而言是不寻常的。但话说回来，美国在拥有这种宗教冲动方面并不是独一无二的。接着清教徒和其他定居者来到新世界的这个思路，很显然，其中蕴含着一种《圣经》层面的理念，即将其比作约书亚引导以色列人进入应许之地。众所周知，约书亚对应许之地的征服伴随着相当多的屠杀。所以从一开始，你就拥有了这种矛盾心理。清教徒和其他定居者来到这里是为了将
I think in the modern period, the United States has been maybe not unique, but has been unusual for great powers in the consistency in which religion has been a factor in shaping why Americans wage war, how they conduct their diplomacy, how they behave themselves in the world. But no, I mean, Americans are unique in having a religious impulse. Following on from this idea of the pilgrims and then other settlers coming to the New World, obviously, there's a kind of scriptural idea there, modelling it on Joshua leading the children of Israel into the Promised Land. And notoriously, Joshua's conquest of the promised land involves quite a lot of slaughter. And so right from the beginning, you have this kind of ambivalence. Are the Puritans, the other settlers there to bring
上帝的话语带给原住民？还是说原住民是必须被消灭的敌人？这种紧张感贯穿了整个向西推进的过程，不是吗？我的意思是，它在一定程度上被世俗化了，但其中确实存在一种矛盾心理。哦，毫无疑问。绝对如此。用“紧张感”来形容甚至比“矛盾心理”更贴切。你知道，新世界中后来成为康涅狄格州和马萨诸塞州等的那些地方，对这些人来说是一个新的耶路撒冷。而且他们定居这些土地并不一定是为了征服，也不是为了消灭已经生活在那里的人。但他们带来的思想与——记住，宗教并不是唯一具有影响力的东西，它不是激励这些人的唯一动力。你还有对土地、定居、扩张、繁衍人口之类事物的渴望。但那些你提到过的宗教思想，提供了一种推动这种扩张的燃料。它还为那些即将成为美国人的人——当时他们还只是殖民者——提供了许多可以用来自圆其说、为这种扩张进行辩护的方式。与此同时，回到多姆之前引用的听众关于“我们如何定义美国的十字军东征”的问题，这不仅关乎扩张，不仅关乎征服，不仅关乎战争以及宗教所能正当化并赋予的侵略性，而且这两种理念也处于极大的紧张关系之中——
the word of God to the natives? Or are the natives the enemy to be got rid of? And that is a kind of tension that informs the whole push westwards, isn't it? I mean, it becomes secularized to a degree, but there is a kind of ambivalence there. Oh, without question. Absolutely. The ambivalence, tension is a better word even than ambivalence. You know, the new world, the states that are now Connecticut and Massachusetts and whatnot, um, were a new Jerusalem for these people. Um, and they weren't necessarily settling those lands in order to conquest, um, and in order to exterminate people who were already living there. But the ideas that they brought forth with them combined with remember religion
一方面是渴望扩张和好战，并且有宗教上的正义性来支撑，但另一方面又存在着和平主义的思想。它们始终处于紧张状态。所以为什么我称之为美国的十字军东征，多姆，你刚才问过，无论是为了和平还是为了战争，其背后几乎总是存在着一种十字军式的精神心态，我认为这就是宗教影响力在整个美国历史的长河（longue durée）中完全体现所在的地方。所以，如果我们稍微深入探讨一下那个早期阶段——我们身处17世纪左右，清教徒（主要来自英国以及英国清教徒色彩浓厚的地区）抵达美洲。就像剑桥。
isn't exclusively influential. It's not the only thing that's motivating these people. You also have, you know, the desire for land and to settle it and to expand and to, to populate and that sort of thing. But the idea is those religious ideas that are there that you talked about, Tom, provide this kind of fuel that just propels this expansion. And it also provides a lot of ways in which, um, the people who become Americans, it's, you know, they're colonists at the time, but the people who become Americans, how they can justify that expansion. At the same time, though, and this gets back to a question that Dom asked from one of your listeners about how are we defining American Crusades? It's not just about expansion. It's not just about conquest. It's not just about war and the aggressiveness that religion can justify and can provide that But then those two ideas are also very much
就像剑桥，还有是的，英格兰东部。我的意思是，看看新英格兰的所有那些地名，对吧？这有什么不同？这种十字军式的冲动，与比如说前往墨西哥或秘鲁等地的西班牙人有什么不同？显然，他们也拥有非常强烈的基督教化精神，历史学家有时认为这只是贪婪的遮羞布，但我认为显然不是。
in tension between the kind of desire to expand and be aggressive. And you have these religious justifications for doing that, but then also the pacifistic ideas. And they're constantly in tension. And so why I would call it American Crusades, Dom, you asked earlier, is that whether it's for peace or whether it's for war there's this crusading mentality behind it um almost always and that's what that's where i see the religious influence as being entirely um over the long duray in american history so if we can dig into that early moment for a second so we're in the sort of 17th century um puritans arriving from you know largely from england and from from heavily Puritan areas of England. Like Cambridge.
他们是真心信仰这一点的。清教徒主义——我的意思是，这是我们世俗欧洲人对美国人略带嘲讽的标准说法：“哦，他们不过是17世纪的清教徒，你们从来没有长大。”这让他们变得不同了吗？我看得出来，作为一个世俗的加拿大人，你很享受这句话。这是一句好台词。
Like Cambridge and like, yeah, Eastern England. I mean, you look at all those names in New England, right? How is that different? And how is the crusading impulse different from, let's say, the Spanish who arrive in Mexico or in Peru or something? I mean, obviously, they also have a very strongly Christianizing ethos, which historians have sometimes thought of as just a fig leaf for greed, but I think clearly isn't.
当然。是的，完全如此。我喜欢这句话。因为它是真的。所以这让他们变得不同了吗？好吧，当然，西班牙人和葡萄牙人行事的方式与他们存在差异。英国定居者、殖民者认为他们自己是不同的。他们非常坚信自己是不同的，
They genuinely believe in it. Does the Puritanism, I mean, it's the standard thing that we secular Europeans say slightly mockingly about Americans. Oh, they're 17th century Puritans. You've never grown up. Does that make them different? I can see you enjoying that line as a secular Canadian. It's a good line.
他们觉得自己更胜一筹，并且认为西班牙人的做法全盘皆错。起初，英国人并不那么热衷于传播福音和皈依美洲原住民，一开始并不是这样。随着时间的推移，这种情况发生了变化。但最初，他们想要土地，想要定居。他们不一定想找到大量的金子。我的意思是，他们当然很乐意找到黄金，但问题是，在马萨诸塞这样的地方根本没有金子。所以他们只想安居乐业。起初，他们只想安安静静地过日子。但很快，就在十年之内，矛盾爆发了，冲突在佩科特人、纳拉甘西特人以及其他原住民部落与定居者之间产生。然后这些冲突演变成暴力和小型战争，演变成真正极其、极其暴力的战争。欧洲人将这种暴力带到了新世界。而美洲原住民也精通战争，且战争手段相当残忍。因此，许多冲突演变成了圣教战争（holy war），部分原因正是由于宗教因素，也就是汤姆之前谈到的那些内容——清教徒、朝圣者以及其他英国定居者从他们的宗教信仰和《圣经》中汲取的那种价值观，在那种信息（或者说不是信息，而是价值观）内部存在着某种紧张感。一旦这种势头建立起来，它就会自行产生强大的推动力。好吧，安德鲁，我可以问你关于另一波定居者——贵格会教徒的问题吗？贵格会教徒，你知道的，他们与英国的清教徒源于同一种新教土壤。但他们——我的意思是，你甚至可以说他们拥有一种侵略性的和平主义。他们引入了一种新的思想流派。这与你们所拥有的传统是如何融合的呢？他们建立了费城——兄弟之爱之城。在17世纪到18世纪的进程中，这些传统是如何与新英格兰的传统相融合的呢？好吧，贵格会教徒是美国和平主义的那些极为重要的奠基人之一。他们不是第一个，但却是最重要的之一。他们带来了强大的——也不是带来，它本来就存在——他们拥有强烈的改良主义精神和冲动，这极大地塑造了美国人如何看待他人以及如何看待更广阔的世界。这并不意味着它随后主导或改变了美国人与他人互动的方式。但这种改良主义冲动是一种良知检查机制，对吧？它是美国人肩头的天使，在他们耳边说：如果你要扩张，如果你要这样做，这些……这些事情，你必须为了正确的理由去做，并且必须用正确的方式去做。我想明确一点，这并不意味着美国人总是用正确的方式行事。因此，发生了许多令人难以置信的暴力事件，历史学家现在认为我们实际上可以称之为种族灭绝，尽管“种族灭绝”这个词是事后追溯的，将它应用到那个时期是不符合历史实际的。但它看起来、感觉起来、听起来确实像我们今天所说的种族灭绝。然而在很多方面，美国的宏伟事业——无论是向西扩张还是海外扩张——都受到这种非常强烈的改良主义和平主义冲动的塑造。如果我们要做这件事，我们就必须为了正确的正当理由并以正确的方式去做。这就是我想要回到“美国的十字军东征”这个概念的地方，这也是美国的十字军东征再度凸显之处。那种历史叙事有点像是定居者对阵——你知道的，主要是英国定居者对阵本土原住民。但北美故事中显然还有其他参与者。所以我们提到了西班牙人和葡萄牙人在墨西哥、巴西等地的活动。但显然还有法国人，他们是天主教徒。这是在18世纪，即17世纪末、18世纪初。正是英国和英国性（Britishness）正在形成的时期。英国有一种观点，认为英国是一个新教堡垒，引领着对抗天主教法国的冲锋。北美的人们是怎么想的呢？因为他们显然也在与法国人作战，对吧？
Of course. Yeah, exactly. I love that line. Because it's true. So does it make them different? Well, there are differences, of course, to how the Spanish and the Portuguese go about their business. The English settlers, the colonists, think that they're different. They very much think that they're
他们在18世纪打了许多针对法国人的战争。他们是否认为法国人——好吧，我知道你是怎么想的，因为你写过关于常态宗教改革战争的书。所以你认为这些是某种在北美大陆上演的欧洲风格的宗教战争吗？部分是。是的，部分是。毫无疑问。我的意思是，多姆，你知道七年战争在美国的名字吗？美国人把七年战争叫什么？
different. They think that they're better, and they think that the Spanish are going about it all the wrong way. Initially, the English aren't all that concerned with spreading the gospel and with converting Native American peoples, initially. That changes over time. But initially, they want to land, they want to settle. They don't necessarily want to find a whole lot of gold. I mean, they'd love to find the gold, but of course, the gold isn't there in somewhere like Massachusetts. And so they just want to settle. And they kind of want to be left alone at first. But very quickly, like within 10 years, there are flashpoints and conflicts that then between the Pequot and the Narragansett and other Aboriginal tribes and the settlers. And that then
他们把美国的七年战争叫什么？毫无疑问，他们一定给起了一些荒谬的头衔。嗯，没有，他们给它起的名字——这正好印证了你刚才问的问题。他们称之为“法国与印第安人战争”。好吧。他们在18世纪打了一系列战争。这些是英国的战争，是帝国主义的英国战争，或者是英国参与的大国战争。在英国，它们被称为奥地利王位继承战争、西班牙王位继承战争或七年战争之类的名字。但在殖民地，它们有不同的称呼。七年战争被称为“法国与印第安人战争”，这个名字说明了一切，因为其中许多战争都是为了打击天主教徒及其印第安盟友，为了消除这种影响，并继续传播这种英国的影响力。或者说这不是英国的影响力，而是英国的定居活动，因为这就是文明。你是在推动文明向前发展。然后到了19世纪，这些思想融合成了一种非常、非常强大的意识形态，它部分是宗教的——并非全部，但部分是宗教的——被称为“天命昭昭”（Manifest Destiny）。
breaks out in violence and small wars in really, really incredibly violent wars. The Europeans take this violence with them over to the New World. Native Americans are practiced at warfare and pretty brutal warfare as well. So it becomes a kind of, a lot of these conflicts turn into a holy war, partly because of that religious, the things that Tom was talking about before, that kind of tension within this sort of message that, or not message, that the values that Puritans and pilgrims and other English settlers have, that they have from their religious faith and from the Bible. And then once there's some momentum that builds up, it just generates its own steam. Well, Andrew, could I ask you about a further wave of settlers who are Quakers? And Quakers, you know, they're bred of the same kind of Protestant milieu in England as the Puritans. But they are, I mean, you could almost say they
是的。而“天命昭昭”随后成为了一个早已在发生的进程的代名词。但对于美国人来说，扩张、领土扩张是他们的天命。随着他们领土的扩张，他们的文明也随之扩张。因为这就是文明，是文明向野蛮的挺进，并驱逐野蛮。他们与上帝达成的契约——这可以追溯到汤姆刚才提到的一些事情——契约的内容是，他们有权这样做、有权扩张，但他们同时也肩负着将他们所扩张的领土文明化的责任。但难道这不也伴随着——我是说，随着新教的发展，或许尤其是随着贵格会的发展，也产生了一种对罪恶的意识吗？例如，贵格会教徒开始领导反对奴役的运动。并且你始终能感受到——我猜这是一种普遍的基督教焦虑——即伟大本身是有问题的，统治、掌握权力、进行定居、主宰他人所需要的一切，从某种意义上说，如果你是一个虔诚的基督徒，可能会成为一个问题。首要的将成为末后的，末后的将成为首在的。你认为，这是否也是从一开始就笼罩在美国伟大之上的阴影？因为我的意思是，我们在当今时代绝对能看到这一点。你认为这源于这种早期现代的基督教土壤吗？我其实没这么想过。不过是的，我认为你说得绝对没错。我想你确实抓住了某种本质。我的意思是，有趣的是，当我们进入19世纪时，奴役制随着轧棉机的发明以及19世纪前半叶奴役制的巨大扩张，已经成为美国根深蒂固的制度，这时，从你刚才讨论的传统中涌现出了一个非常强大的废奴主义运动。但那个废奴主义运动同时也具有相当强的扩张主义色彩，并且非常坚信“天命昭昭”，只要奴役制不随之蔓延就行。因此，反奴役并不一定总是与和平主义相契合，或者说与……事实上，许多和平主义者，比如“天命昭昭”这个词的创造者约翰·L·奥沙利文，他本人就认为自己是一个基督教和平主义者。他信仰天命昭昭，不是因为他们必须去消灭所有的印第安人，而是因为这就是上帝的意旨。我的意思是，美国将会扩张，其他一切都会随之而来，因为这是正义的，这正是历史应当展开的方式。
have a kind of aggressive pacifism. They kind of introduce a new strain of thought. And how does that fuse with the traditions that you have? So they found Philadelphia, city of brotherly love. How did those traditions fuse with those in New England over the course of the 17th and then into the 18th centuries? Well, the Quakers are one of those really important founders of American pacifism. They're not the first, but they're one of the most important. And they bring a strong, they don't bring it, it's already there, but they have a very strong reformist ethos and impulse that heavily shapes how Americans view others and how they view the wider world. It doesn't mean that it then dominates or changes the way Americans interact with others. But that reformist impulse is a kind of conscience check, right? It's the angel on the shoulder of Americans who say, if you're going
没错，确实如此。所以，所有这些思想在某种程度上既是美国特有的，同时又是普遍的，因为天主教就是普遍的。基督教是一个普遍化、全球化的宗教。它是为全人类服务的。众所周知，当美洲定居者起来反抗他们受上帝膏立的君主——国王乔治三世，并犯下叛乱的致命罪行时，他们将这场叛乱包装成了一场对普遍权利的捍卫、对人性普遍理解的捍卫。国父们对这种普遍启蒙价值观的承诺，是否表达了某种在其骨子里属于基督教普遍主义的东西？你用这样一个充满倾向性的问题提问，以至于你只能回答“是”。如果我说“不”，整个节目是不是就要停播了？感谢收听。不过，这难道不也是对美国存在多种不同基督教流派这一事实的一种回应吗？所以不仅仅是新教的各个分支，你知道的，也有天主教徒在马里兰州等地定居。因此，如果你能将所有这些基督教的分歧掩埋起来，并将其重新包装成一种某种程度上超越基督教身份的普遍方案，那么你就能发动一场革命战争。嗯，对于你的问题，答案是肯定的。而且两者兼而有之。从国父们开始直到后来，一种非常普遍的现象是，无论是基督教——尽管他们中的许多人并非传统的基督徒——还是我们后来所说的“美国主义”（Americanism），都被认为或被假定为普遍价值。因此，长期以来，这种本质上属于基督教的身份认同——即使人们不一定像许多国父那样是四处征战的基督徒——这种传播文明、传播文明福祉（它继承自基督教，这也是基督教传教热忱的背后动力）的渴望，同样是美国人身份的核心，并且在很大程度上构成了美国人在世界上面貌的核心。我想问一个关于美国独立战争的问题。所以，你知道的，革命战争，也就是他们所说的独立战争。在这场战争中——你在书中写道，宗教是独立战争爆发和进程的核心。
to expand, if you're going to do this, these these sorts of things, you have to do them for the right reasons and you have to do them in the right ways. I want to be clear, it doesn't mean that Americans always do them in the right way. So there's a lot of incredible violence that happens that historians now think we can actually call it genocide, even though the term is ex post facto, it's a historical to apply it to that period. But it does look and feel and sound like what we would today call genocide. And yet, in a lot of ways, the American project, be it Westward expansion or overseas is shaped by that very strong reformist pacifistic impulse. If we're going to do this, we have to do it for the right reasons and in the right ways. And that's kind of where I go
我看得出来你闭上了眼睛，正在拼命回忆自己的书。这太棒了。这令人感到非常欣慰。我们都会在这个问题上栽跟头。那么他们是怎么看的呢？你认为18世纪末的美国人看待那场战争的方式，是否与他们17世纪的英国前辈看待英国内战的方式相似？因为众所周知，他们曾将查理·斯图亚特视为血腥人，他们认为自己是受天命委任的，他们正在为维护真正的新教信仰而战，诸如此类。天主教徒就在大门外之类的说法。美国独立战争中是否也存在一点这种元素？你认为其中是否存在一种专制暴政和天主教暴政的威胁潜影？这种威胁是否隐现于他们想象力的背景之中？我认为它确实隐现着。我的意思是，我认为它就位于他们想象力的最前端，即使对我们来说——甚至对当时的某些人来说——它看起来并不是那么合乎逻辑，特别是考虑到那些实际上是奴隶主、将人当作财产拥有的人，竟然指责英国乔治国王和议会是奴隶主，是在奴役美洲殖民者，这在许多层面上当然是极其虚伪的。不，他们绝对是这么相信的，但并非所有人都这么信。所以这可以说是那种高度二元论的世界观中的一条线索。而且，如果你要发动一场十字军东征或一场战争，你必须为最崇高的事业和最充分的理由而战。这往往会导致人们夸大他们发动战争的意识形态原因。而宗教则起到了助推作用。不过，在独立战争中，这种宗教色彩并不像在英国内战中那样普遍，因为许多国父并不是传统的宗教信徒。因此，他们没有像17世纪奥利弗·克伦威尔那样使用宗教。但它确实存在。那么我们在这里稍事休息。当我们回来时，让我们来探讨一下美国南北战争。我是玛丽娜·海德。
to go back to that idea of American Crusades, where American Crusades comes back in. That sort of story is kind of settlers versus, you know, English, largely English settlers versus indigenous people. But there are obviously other players in the story for North America. So we mentioned the Spanish and the Portuguese
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家加更节目以及提前购买现场门票的特权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回来。我们正在与剑桥大学的安德鲁·普雷斯顿教授一起讨论美国的圣战或美国的十字军东征。
in Mexico and Brazil and so on. But obviously there's the French who are Catholics. And this is, say, the 18th century, late 17th, early 18th century. It's the point at which Britain and Britishness are being created. And there's an idea in Britain of Britain as a sort of Protestant redoubt leading the charge against Catholic France. What do people think in North America? Because they're obviously fighting the French too, right?
汤姆，你想带我们进入美国南北战争的话题吗？从美国独立战争过渡到19世纪，回到我之前提出的问题，因为这似乎是北美大陆上爆发的最残酷战争的根本所在。美国人自己是否出于基督教的原因将此视为一个问题？这是否构成了导致南北战争爆发的各种原因交织的一部分？这种由基督教理解孕育出的对奴役制的内疚感？对某些人来说，毫无疑问，绝对是的。我在书中关于美国南北战争的论点是，它成为了美国第一场人道主义干预战争，其原因正如你刚才所说的大多数，汤姆。在南北战争爆发时，大多数美国人并不是废奴主义者。大多数北方的白人反对奴役制，但不是出于道德原因，不是因为这是一种罪恶，而是因为奴役制正在腐蚀美洲共和国，并且阻碍美国成为一个扩张性的资本主义强国。但随着南北战争本身的进程——林肯在当选总统时也持这种观点，他当时并不是废奴主义者，他说过：“如果我们能在奴役制现存的地方保留它，从而避免南北战争并阻止其扩张，那也没问题。”但一旦战争爆发，它便具有了自身的逻辑和势头，林肯和其他北方白人随后便拥抱了终结奴役制的道德十字军，将其作为维护联邦的一种方式，这两者最终融合在了一起。
They're fighting lots of wars against the French in the 18th century. Do they think of them as kind of, well, I know what you think they think, because you write about wars of permanent reformation. So do you think these are kind of European-style religious wars fought out in the North American continent? In part. Yeah, in part. Definitely. I mean, you know, Dom, you know the American name for the Seven Years' War. What do the Americans call the Seven Years' War?
林肯和其他人在1862、1863、1864年的南北战争中所使用的语言具有高度的道德主义色彩。它具有高度的宗教色彩。无论是福音派卫理公会信徒、浸信会信徒，还是作为基督教中较为进步流派的一员的统一派或贵格会信徒，这些基督教废奴主义者们的修辞和语言都被林肯所借鉴。他们还不断发表布道词、撰写无数的小册子、创作广受欢迎的歌曲。然后我在研究中发现非常有趣的是，在后来的战争中，即1898-1899年的美西战争，以及20世纪的一战中，美国人都有意识地将南北战争作为他们进行人道主义干预战争的模型，将其视为一场由上帝裁决的正义之战。关于林肯。
What do they call the American Seven Years' War? They've got to give us some nonsense title, no doubt. Well, no, they give it, I mean, this speaks exactly to what you were just asking. They call it the French and Indian War. Okay. And they fight a series of wars in the 18th century. And they're British wars, they're imperial British wars, or they're great power wars that Britain fights. And they're known to people in Britain as, you know, the War of Austrian Succession or the War of Spanish Succession or the Seven Years War or something like that. And they're known by different names in the colonies. And the name for the Seven Years' War, the French and Indian War, says it all because a lot of these wars are about fighting the papists and their Indian allies and sort of getting rid of that influence and continuing to spread this kind of English influence. Or it's not English influence, it's English settlement, because that's civilization. And you're sort of pushing civilization. And then when you get to the 19th century, those ideas become fused in a very, very powerful ideology that's partly religious, not entirely, but partly religious called manifest destiny.
所以林肯是一个非常有趣的人物，不是吗？因为关于林肯的刻板印象是，他是一个典型的……他就是美国人。在公众心中，他在某种程度上相当于英国人格莱斯顿那样的美国人物。你知道的，他代表了最好、最高尚的改良主义冲动。但不同之处在于，英国人格莱斯顿非常明显是一个严厉的新教徒。林肯的父母，我想他的父母是浸信会信徒吧？他们是加尔文主义者。
Yeah. And manifest destiny then is the is the is a name for a process that had already been happening. But the Americans, it's their manifest destiny to expand, to expand their territory. And as they expand their territory, they expand their civilization. Because it is civilization, it's civilization moving into barbarism and sort of pushing out barbarism. And the pact with God that they have, which goes back to some of the things Tom was mentioning earlier, the pact is that they have a right to do this, to expand, but then they also have a responsibility to civilize the territories that they're expanding into. But isn't that also with, I mean, so with Protestantism, perhaps particularly with Quakerism, there is a
但他自己——我的意思是，林肯本人并不是传统的宗教信徒，对吧？他是个自然神论者吗？完全不是。甚至都不是。我的意思是，林肯本人并不是传统的宗教信徒，对吧？完全不是。嗯，他身上受到许多不同影响的影响，他信仰许多不同的东西。你无法像对待许多美国总统那样轻易给他定性，比如托马斯·杰斐逊、罗纳德·里根以及介于他们之间的许多人。很难确切指明他的信仰究竟是什么。而且他并没有表现出太多的宗教色彩，在成为总统之前，几乎没有什么证据表明他拥有宗教价值观或宗教信仰。他的演讲中并没有太多的宗教修辞之类的东西。但在南北战争期间，宗教、宗教修辞、意象以及对《圣经》的引用成为了林肯演讲中的重要组成部分。它们成为了他向美国人民描绘这场战争的重要方式。有时是显式的宗教措辞，有时则只是他演讲中那种《圣经》般的韵律，以至于人们将他的演讲视为布道词，弗雷德里克·道格拉斯曾有一句名言称赞他的第二次就职演说——我这里是意译——就像美国历史上最伟大的布道词一样。但安德鲁，难道这不——这难道不反映出这样一个事实：美国深深浸润在基督教实践和基督教假设之中，以至于在某种程度上，无论你是否是一个去教堂、读《圣经》的基督徒，你依然会反映出那些根深蒂固、你根本无法摆脱的假设？
consciousness of sin as well. So Quakers, for instance, start to lead the campaign against slavery. And there is a sense that you have throughout, I suppose it's a kind of universal Christian anxiety, that greatness in itself is problematic, that everything that it takes to rule, to be powerful, to settle, to dominate others, in a way, if you're a devout Christian, can be an issue. The first should be last, the last should be first. And is that something that is kind of a shadow over American greatness from the beginning as well, do you think? Because I mean, we see that absolutely in the present day. Is that something that you think originates from this kind of early
是的，我想这绝对正确。在某些情况下，例如在美西战争期间，当威廉·麦金莱决定吞并——这是美国对殖民化的委婉说法——当他决定吞并菲律宾时，他出于明确的基督教原因这样做，麦金莱是一个读《圣经》、去教堂的卫理公会信徒，这绝非巧合。但汤姆，你说得绝对没错，这种精神风貌，尤其是在19世纪中叶以及其他时期（比如宗教完全充斥着一切的20世纪50年代），几乎是让人无法逃避的。
modern Christian seedbed? I hadn't actually thought about it like that. But yes, I think you're absolutely right. I think you're absolutely onto something. I mean, the interesting thing is, by the time we get to the 19th century, where slavery is an embedded institution in the United States with the cotton gin and the vast expansion of slavery in the first half of the 19th century, there then emerges a very strong abolitionist movement that comes out of this tradition that you're talking about. But that abolitionist tradition is also quite expansionist and believes pretty strongly in manifest destiny, just as long as slavery doesn't follow. So the anti-slavery doesn't actually map out always onto pacifism or onto... And in fact, a lot of pacifists, like the coiner of the phrase, Manifest Destiny, John L. O'Sullivan, he himself considered himself a Christian pacifist. And he believed in Manifest Destiny, not because they had to go and exterminate all the Indians, but because this was just what God meant. I mean, America would expand and everything else would just follow because this was just and this was exactly how history should be unfolding.
现代基督教的摇篮？我实际上没这么想过。不过是的，我想你是完全正确的。我想你确实切中要害了。我的意思是，有趣的是，当我们进入19世纪时，随着轧棉机的出现以及19世纪前半叶奴隶制的急剧扩张，奴隶制已成为美国根深蒂固的制度，这时，从你刚才提到的传统中涌现出了一个非常强大的废奴运动。但那个废奴传统也具有相当强的扩张性，并且相当坚信昭昭天命，只要奴隶制不跟随就行。因此，反奴隶制实际上并不总是与和平主义相契合，或者说……事实上，许多和平主义者，比如创造“昭昭天命”这个词的约翰·L·奥沙利文，他本人就认为自己是一个基督教和平主义者。他信仰昭昭天命，不是因为他们必须去消灭所有的印第安人，而是因为这就是上帝的旨意。我的意思是，美国将会扩张，其他一切都会随之而来，因为这是正义的，这正是历史应该展开的方式。
Yeah, right. So the idea that all these ideas are in some way specific to America, but also are universal because that's to be Catholic is to be universal. Christianity is a universalizing, globalizing religion. It's for absolutely everybody. Famously, when the American settlers come to rebel against their divinely anointed liege lord, King George III, and commit the fatal sin of rebellion, they cast this rebellion as something that is universe defense of universal rights a universal understanding of what humanity is does this commitment of the founding fathers to kind of universal enlightenment values is that an expression of something that in its in its marrow
是的，没错。因此，所有这些思想在某种程度上既是美国特有的，但同时也是普遍的，因为天主教化就是普遍化。基督教是一种普世的、全球化的宗教。它绝对是为了每一个人。众所周知，当美国定居者起来反抗他们神圣膏立的封建领主乔治三世国王，并犯下叛乱这一致命罪行时，他们将这场叛乱包装为对普遍权利的防御、对人性是什么的普遍理解。国父们对这种普遍启蒙价值观的承诺，是否表达了一种在骨子里
is of kind of an expression of christian universalism you've asked that question in such a loaded way that you can only answer yes well if yes. If I say no, is this going to get, is the whole program going to stop? Thanks for listening. But also, is it not also a response to the fact that actually there are multiple different variants of Christianity in America? So not just kind of Protestant subsects, but, you know, there are Catholics settled in Maryland or whatever as well. So that if you can kind of bury all these Christian differences and kind of rebrand them as a kind of universal package that somehow transcends Christian identity, then you can launch a revolutionary war. I mean, to your question, the answer is yes. And it's both. And something that was very prevalent from the founders onwards is that both Christianity, even though a lot of them weren't conventionally Christian, and what we would later call Americanism, were both considered to be, they were assumed to be
某种程度上是基督教普世主义的表达？你提出的这个问题带有如此强的倾向性，以至于你只能回答“是”。好吧，如果我说“不”，这会导致整个节目停播吗？感谢收听。但同时，这难道不是对美国存在多种不同基督教流派这一事实的回应吗？不仅是各种新教分支，你知道的，还有在马里兰州等地定居的天主教徒之类。因此，如果你能将所有这些基督教的分歧掩埋起来，并将其重新包装为一个某种程度上超越基督教身份的普世整体，那么你就可以发动一场革命战争。我的意思是，对于你的问题，答案是“是”。而且两者兼而有之。从国父们开始就非常盛行的一点是，无论是基督教——尽管他们中的许多人并不是传统意义上的基督徒——还是我们后来称之为“美国主义”的东西，都被认为是，它们被假定为
universal values. And so for a long time, this Christian identity that is inherently, even if people weren't necessarily crusading Christians themselves, like a lot of the founders, this desire to spread civilization, to spread the blessings of civilization, which is inheriting Christianity, that's behind Christian conversionism, is also very much at the heart of what it means to be an American, and very much what it means to be at the heart of what it means to be an American in the world. Just a question about the American Revolution. So, you know, the Revolutionary War, as they call it, the War of Independence. So in that war, I mean, you wrote in your book, religion was central to the outbreak and course of the Revolutionary War.
普遍价值观。因此，在很长一段时间里，这种天生具有的基督教身份——即使人们不一定像许多国父那样本身就是到处征战的基督徒——这种传播文明、传播文明福祉的渴望（这是继承自基督教的，这也是基督教皈依主义背后的动力），也是美国人身份核心的重要部分，并且在很大程度上构成了美国人在世界上面貌的核心。顺便问一个关于美国革命的问题。所以，你知道的，革命战争，正如他们所称的，独立战争。那么在那场战争中，我的意思是，你在书中写过，宗教是革命战争爆发和进程的核心。
I can see you've got your eyes closed as you're desperately trying to recall your own book. That's great to see. That's very gratifying. It trips us all up. So do they see that? Do you think that late 18th century Americans saw that war in a similar way to the way in which their 17th century English predecessors had seen the Civil War in England? So they had famously seen Charles Stuart as the man of blood, and they thought they were appointed by Providence, and they were fighting to preserve the true Protestant faith and all this sort of thing. The papists are at the gates and stuff. Is there a bit of an element of that with the American War of Independence as well? Do you think that
我能看出你闭上眼睛，正在拼命回忆自己的书。很高兴看到这一点。这真是太令人欣慰了。这把我们所有人都难倒了。那么他们是怎么看的呢？你认为18世纪末的美国人看待那场战争的方式，与他们17世纪英国前辈看待英国内战的方式相似吗？他们曾著名地将查理·斯图亚特视为血腥人，他们认为自己是由天意指派的，他们是在为捍卫真正的新教信仰以及诸如此类的事情而战。天主教徒就在大门外之类的。美国独立战争中是否也有那么一点这方面的成分？你认为
there's a sort of threat of absolutist tyranny and potpourri and stuff? Is that looming somewhere at the back of their imagination? I think it's looming. I mean, I think it's right at the very front of their imagination, even if not just to us, but to some people at the time, it didn't seem very logical, especially with people who actually were slave masters, who actually owned people as property, that they were then accusing the British of King George and of Parliament of being slave masters and enslaving the American colonists, which of course is incredibly hypocritical on so many levels. No, they absolutely believed it, but not everyone believed it. And so it's sort of one strand of that very dichotomous view of way of looking at the world. And also, if you're going to launch a kind of crusade or a war, you would have to do something for the very best of causes and for the very, very best of reasons. And then that often led people to exaggerate the sort of ideological reasons for why they were doing it. And religion helped.
是否存在一种绝对主义暴政、天主教和诸如此类的威胁？这是否在他们的想象力背后隐约浮现？我认为它正在隐约浮现。我的意思是，我认为它就在他们想象力的最前端，即使不仅对我们而言，对当时的一些人来说，这看起来并不是那么符合逻辑，特别是那些实际上是奴隶主、实际上将人作为财产拥有的人，他们随后竟然指责英国国王乔治和议会是奴隶主，在奴隶化美国殖民者，这在许多层面上当然是极其虚伪的。不，他们绝对是这么认为的，但并不是所有人都这么认为。因此，这可以说是那种对世界有着二元对立看法的其中一个脉络。而且，如果你要发动一场十字军东征或战争，你就必须为了最崇高的事业和绝对最崇高的理由去做点什么。然后这往往会导致人们夸大他们为什么要这样做的意识形态理由。而宗教对此有所帮助。
Now, in the revolution, it's not as prevalent as it was, say, in the English Civil War, because a lot of the founders weren't conventionally religious. So they didn't use religion in the same way that, say, Oliver Cromwell would have used it in the 17th century. But it's certainly there. So let's take a quick break here. And when we come back, let's get into the American Civil War. I'm Marina Hyde.
现在，在革命中，它不像比如说在英国内战中那样普遍，因为许多国父并不是传统意义上的宗教人士。所以他们没有以17世纪奥利弗·克伦威尔那种方式来使用宗教。但它确实存在。那么我们在这里休息一下。当我们回来时，让我们来聊聊美国内战。我是玛丽娜·海德。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back. We are talking about America's holy wars or America's crusades with Professor Andrew Preston from Cambridge.
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《余下皆娱乐》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦花絮。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告节目、独家单集并提前获得现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回来。我们正在与剑桥大学的安德鲁·普雷斯顿教授一起讨论美国的圣战或美国的十字军东征。
Now, Tom, would you like to take us into the American Civil War? So moving on from the American Revolution into the 19th century, coming back to the question I asked before, because it does seem fundamental to the most brutal war that has been fought on North American soil. Is this seen by Americans themselves for Christian reasons as a problem? Is it feeding into the kind of the nexus of causes that will result in the Civil War? A guilt about slavery bred off kind of Christian understanding? For some people, unquestionably, absolutely. The argument that I make in my book about the American Civil War is that it became America's first war of humanitarian intervention, for a lot of the reasons that you just said, Tom. Most Americans at the time weren't abolitionists
现在，汤姆，你想带我们进入美国内战吗？那么从美国革命过渡到19世纪，回到我之前提出的问题，因为它似乎对在北美大陆上打过的那场最残酷的战争至关重要。美国人自己是否出于基督教的原因将这视为一个问题？这是否正在融入将导致内战的各种原因的交织网络中？一种由基督教理解孕育出的对奴隶制的内疚感？对某些人来说，毫无疑问，绝对是的。我在书中关于美国内战的论点是，它成为了美国第一场人道主义干预战争，原因有很多，就像你刚才说的，汤姆。当时的绝大多数美国人并不是废奴主义者
at the outbreak of the Civil War. Most white Northerners were anti-slavery, but not for moral reasons, not because it was a sin, but because of how it was corrupting the American Republic and how it was preventing America from becoming this expansive capitalist power. But over the course of the Civil War itself, and Abraham Lincoln held that view when he became president, he wasn't an abolitionist. And he said, you know, if we can preserve slavery where it is and avoid the Civil War and prevent it from expanding, then that's fine. But once the war breaks out and it acquires a logic and a momentum of its own, people like Lincoln and other white northerners then embrace the moral crusade of ending slavery as a way to preserve the union and the two become
在内战爆发时。大多数北方白人是反奴隶制的，但不是出于道德原因，不是因为这是一种罪恶，而是因为奴隶制正在腐蚀美利坚共和国，并且阻碍了美国成为一个扩张性的资本主义强权。但在内战本身的发展过程中——亚伯拉罕·林肯在当选总统时也持这种观点，他不是废奴主义者，他说过，你知道的，如果我们能在奴隶制现有的地方保护它，避免内战并防止其扩张，那也没问题。但一旦战争爆发，它便获得了一种自身的逻辑和动力，像林肯和其他北方白人这样的人随后便拥护了终结奴隶制的道德十字军东征，将其作为维护联邦的一种方式，这两者融为一体
fused. And the language that Lincoln and others use then in the civil war in 1862, 63, 64, is highly moralistic. It's highly religious. Christian abolitionists who are either evangelical Methodists or Baptists or they're Unitarians or Quakers on the sort of more progressive end of Christianity, he's borrowing their rhetoric, he's borrowing their language. They're also giving constant sermons, writing constant pamphlets, writing songs that become very widely popular. And then what I found really interesting in my research is that later on in later wars, in 1898-99, the Spanish-American War, into the 20th century in the First World War, Americans are consciously adopting the Civil War as their model for a war of humanitarian intervention, a righteous war that is then justified by God. Just on Lincoln.
林肯和其他人在1862、63、64年的内战中所使用的语言具有高度的道德主义色彩。它具有高度的宗教色彩。无论是属于福音派循道宗、浸礼宗，还是属于基督教中较为进步的唯理论者或贵格会的基督教废奴主义者，林肯都在借用他们的修辞，借用他们的语言。他们还不断发表布道，不断撰写小册子，创作广受欢迎的歌曲。然后我在研究中发现非常有趣的是，后来在后来的战争中，在1898-99年的美西战争中，以及进入20世纪的第一次世界大战中，美国人是有意识地将内战作为他们进行人道主义干预战争的模范，这是一场正义的战争，并由上帝来赋予其正当性。就说林肯。
So Lincoln is a really interesting character, isn't he? Because the sort of stereotype of Lincoln is that he's a classic, you know, he's the American. It's to some extent in the public mind is the American equivalent of somebody like Gladstone. You know, he represents the very best, the most high-minded reformist kind of impulses. But the difference is that somebody like Gladstone in Britain is very obviously a kind of a stern Protestant. Lincoln's parents, I think, his parents were Baptists, weren't they? They were Calvinists.
所以林肯是一个非常有趣的人物，不是吗？因为对林肯的刻板印象是，他是一个典型的，你知道的，他就是美国人。在公众心目中，他在某种程度上相当于英国人格莱斯顿那样的美国版本。你知道的，他代表了最好、最高尚的改良主义冲动。但不同之处在于，英国的格莱斯顿显然是一个严厉的新教徒。林肯的父母，我想，他的父母是浸礼宗信徒，对吧？他们是加尔文主义者。
But he's not, I mean, Lincoln's not himself conventionally religious, right? Isn't he a deist? Not at all. Not even. Yeah. I mean, Lincoln's not himself conventionally religious, right? Not at all. Yeah, well, he has a number of different influences on him and he believes a number of different things. And you can't pin him down like a lot of American presidents like Thomas Jefferson, like Ronald Reagan and a lot of people in between. Very difficult to pin down exactly what his faith was. And he didn't show a lot of religious, there was little evidence of his religious values or religious beliefs until he became president. There's not a lot of religious rhetoric in his speeches and whatnot. But during the Civil War, religion and religious
但他不是，我的意思是，林肯本人并不是传统意义上的宗教人士，对吧？他不是自然神论者吗？完全不是。甚至都不是。是的。我的意思是，林肯本人并不是传统意义上的宗教人士，对吧？完全不是。是的，好吧，有许多不同的因素影响着他，他信仰许多不同的东西。你无法像对待许多美国总统（如托马斯·杰斐逊、罗纳德·里根以及其间的许多人）那样轻易地定义他。很难确切地断定他的信仰究竟是什么。在成为总统之前，他没有表现出太多的宗教色彩，几乎没有什么证据表明他的宗教价值观或宗教信仰。在他的演讲等内容中，没有太多的宗教修辞。但在内战期间，宗教以及宗教
rhetoric and imagery and quotations from scripture become a big part of Lincoln's speeches. They become a big part of how he portrays the war to the American people. Sometimes it's explicit religious phrasing, but sometimes it's just the kind of biblical cadence of his speeches, to the extent that people considered his speeches as sermons, and Frederick Douglass famously called his second inaugural address, something like, I'm paraphrasing here, but like the greatest sermon in American history. But Andrew, doesn't that, I mean, doesn't that reflect the fact that America is so saturated in Christian practice, Christian assumptions, that in a way, it doesn't matter whether you are, you know, you're a church going, Bible reading Christian, you're still going to reflect assumptions that are so deep rooted that you can't really escape them.
修辞、意象和圣经引文成为林肯演讲的重要组成部分。它们成为他向美国人民描绘这场战争的重要方式。有时是显式的宗教措辞，但有时只是他演讲中那种圣经般的韵律，以至于人们将他的演讲视为布道。弗雷德里克·道格拉斯曾有一句名言称他的第二次就职演说——我这里是意译——就像美国历史上最伟大的布道。但是，安德鲁，难道这不意味着，我的意思是，这难道不反映出美国浸润在基督教实践和基督教假设中是如此之深，以至于在某种程度上，无论你是不是一个去教堂、读圣经的基督徒，你依然会反映出那些根深蒂固、你无法真正逃脱的假设吗？
Yeah, I think that's absolutely right. There are instances in which, say, during the Spanish-American War, when William McKinley decides to annex, which is the American euphemism for colonize, when it decides to annex the Philippines, and he does so for explicitly Christian reasons, it's not a coincidence that McKinley was a Bible-reading, church-going Methodist. But you're absolutely right, Tom, that the ethos, especially in the mid-19th century and at other times like the 1950s, when religion absolutely suffuses everything, that it's almost impossible to escape.
是的，我认为这绝对是正确的。有些情况下，比方说在美西战争期间，当威廉·麦金莱决定吞并——这是美国人对殖民化的委婉说法——当他决定吞并菲律宾时，他是出于明确的基督教原因这样做的。麦金莱是一个读圣经、去教堂的循道宗信徒，这并非巧合。但你说得完全正确，汤姆，这种精神气质，尤其是在19世纪中期以及其他时期（比如20世纪50年代，当时宗教绝对渗透到了一切事物中），几乎是无法逃脱的。
And that religion, so obviously we've talked about it as Christian a lot. Well, it is Christian. But there are all kinds of variations. And is it too simplistic to say that there are that there are specific i mean you talked about the sort of pacifist strain which obviously is represented by quakers and stuff i mean when you stand back and look at let's say the 19th century can you say that there is a distinct kind of episcopalian that's the obviously the the u.s equivalent of the church of england effectively or dissenting kind of Methodist, Baptist, or indeed Catholic, are there distinct views of America and its place in the world? Or by that point, has there
这种宗教，显然我们之前经常把它归结为基督教。嗯，它确实是基督教。但其中包含各种各样的变体。如果说存在某种特定的——我是说你刚才提到了某种和平主义传统，这显然以贵格会等教派为代表——那么当我们退一步来看，比方说19世纪，我们能否说存在一种独特的圣公宗（这显然是英国国教会实际上在美洲的对应版本），或者是不同风格的卫理公会、浸信会，抑或是天主教？对于美国及其在世界上的地位，是否存在截然不同的观点？还是说，到了那个时候，已经
become a kind of, you know, as Tom suggested earlier, this sort of melting pot-ish kind of, you know, American civil religion that trumps all of that and transcends it? Well, I think there's definitely the civil religion that's there. And it gets to, you know, the point that Tom just made that this kind of, um, that religion suffuses everything. Therefore, uh,
出现了一种，就像汤姆刚才所暗示的那样，类似于熔炉一样的、能够压倒并超越这一切的美国公民宗教？嗯，我认为公民宗教确实存在。这就印证了汤姆刚刚提出的观点，即这种，嗯，宗教渗透到了各个方面。因此，呃，
Christianity or Judeo Christianity, although that term doesn't, it isn't coined until the 20th century, that it suffuses everything to the point that you have the emergence of a kind of civil religion. I mean, both of you have pointed out that there was a, um,
基督教或犹太-基督教传统——尽管这个词直到20世纪才被创造出来——渗透到了每一个角落，以至于催生了一种公民宗教。我的意思是，你们两位都指出，当时存在着，嗯，
that there were many types of Protestantism, but also Catholicism, other Christians, Lutherans, for instance, and then Jews who were present in the United States in the 19th and early 20th centuries. But really, until the middle of the 20th century, until World War II, the United States is a Protestant nation. And so I wouldn't necessarily say that there was an Episcopalian stamp on American politics or foreign policy or a Methodist stamp, but there absolutely was a Protestant stamp. And everyone else had to conform to that Protestant norm, be they Catholics or Mormons or Jews. And they lived, as Franklin Roosevelt said,
存在着多种形式的新教，同时也有天主教、其他基督教派（例如路德宗），以及在19和20世纪初就已经存在于美国的犹太人。但事实上，直到20世纪中叶二战爆发之前，美国一直是一个新教国家。因此，我不会强行断言美国政治或外交政策中带有某种圣公会的烙印或卫理公会的烙印，但它绝对带有新教的烙印。其他所有人都必须顺从这种新教规范，无论是天猫人、摩门教徒还是犹太人。正如富兰克林·罗斯福所说，他们生活在——
who was actually very, very pluralistic, very tolerant when it came to religion. He appointed more Jews and Catholics to his cabinet than any president before him had. In fact, I think he appointed more Jews and Catholics to his administration than all presidents before him combined. But he did make the observation, not his own judgment, but the observation that the United States was a Protestant nation, and that Jews and Catholics lived there at the sufferance of Protestants. It's a remarkable thing to say. Yeah. Yeah. And also America's wars overseas.
他本人其实非常具有多元主义精神，在宗教问题上极其宽容。他任命的犹太人和天主教徒进入内阁的数量，比他之前的任何一位总统都要多。事实上，我认为他任命到政府中的犹太人和天主教徒人数，超过了他之前所有总统的总和。但他确实曾发表过这样的观察——这不是他个人的好恶判断，而是他的观察——即美国是一个新教国家，犹太人和天主教徒是在新教徒的容忍下才得以在那里生存。这话听起来真非同寻常。是的，确实如此。而且，这也体现在美国海外发动的战争中。
So I guess the, the, the annexation, you know, war against Mexico in the 1840s. And then of course the, the annexation of the Philippines and the war against Spain and Cuba and so on.
所以我想，18世纪40年代针对墨西哥的兼并战争，当然还有后来对菲律宾的兼并，以及针对西班牙和古巴的战争等等。
These are all Catholic powers that they're targeting. I mean, is that, is that a coincidence or is that a motivator? It's not a coincidence. I want to be careful in saying it's a motivator, because if you say it's a motivator, you're implying that those wars would not have happened without the religious angle, which I don't think is true. I mean, the war against Mexico was clearly one great big land grab. The war over Cuba was not a land grab. And neither was initially the war over the Philippines. But it becomes that when the US decides to colonize it.
这些他们攻击的目标全都是天主教国家。我的意思是，这究竟是巧合，还是某种动机？这绝非巧合。不过在将其称为“动机”时我必须谨慎，因为如果你说它是动机，就意味着如果没有宗教因素，那些战争就不会爆发，而我认为事实并非如此。我的意思是，针对墨西哥的战争显然是一场赤裸裸的大规模土地掠夺。而关于古巴的战争则算不上土地掠夺，对菲律宾的战争最初也不是。但当美国决定将其殖民化时，性质就变了。
So religion isn't isn't making these wars happen, but it's it's shaping how they're how they're fought. It's driving some of the reasons why they're waged. And those are very Protestant ideas. And I'll give you an example from the Philippines. When the United States fought the Spanish-American War, the initial cause was Cuba. And it was over all those awful things that the Spanish were doing to the Cubans and the Cubans were fighting for Cuba Libre for their own independence. And that was 90 miles from the Florida shore. So it mattered a lot to Americans. Eventually, the U.S. went to war to kick Spain out of Cuba. And part of that war was fought in the Philippines as a separate theater of the war, simply because the U. Kong to Manila, sank the Spanish fleet, so it couldn't then sail all the way around the world to participate in the main theater of fighting, which was Cuba. But in knocking out the Spanish fleet in the Philippines, the United States now was the sovereign power, as it were, in the Philippines. And so McKinley was faced with this question, what to do with the Philippines? Do you give them independence? Well, he said, no, of course not, because they're completely unready for independence, self-government. They're not educated. They're not ready for it, which, of course, had incredibly racist overtones and
所以，宗教并没有直接导致这些战争的爆发，但它塑造了战争的打法，并推动了部分战争爆发的原因。这些都是非常具有新教色彩的想法。我可以给你们举一个来自菲律宾的例子。当美国与西班牙开战时，最初的起因是古巴。起因是西班牙人对古巴人犯下的那些恶劣行径，而古巴人为了争取“自由古巴”（Cuba Libre）以及他们自己的独立而战。古巴距离佛罗里达海岸只有90英里，因此它对美国人至关重要。最终，美国参战以将西班牙赶出古巴。作为战争的一部分，其中一个战场设在了菲律宾，这只是战争的一个独立战区，原因仅仅是美国舰队开到了马尼拉，击沉了西班牙舰队，这样西班牙舰队就无法绕过整个世界来参与主战场——也就是古巴的战斗。然而，由于摧毁了西班牙在菲律宾的舰队，美国转眼间成了菲律宾名义上的主权掌控者。因此，麦金莱面临着这样一个问题：拿菲律宾怎么办？是给他们独立吗？嗯，他说，不，当然不能，因为他们根本没有准备好迎接独立和自治。他们没有受过教育，没有做好准备——当然，这种说法带有极其浓重的种族主义色彩，并伴随着
racist implications and motivations. But he wasn't prepared at all to give the Filipinos their independence, even though they, too, had been fighting for it, just like the Cubans. He said, do we give it over to another imperial power? And he said, no, that would be stupid. We can't do that. We can't just hand it to, we've taken it from Spain. We're not now not going to hand it to the British or the French. And so it was an incredibly difficult decision, extremely polarizing politically. And then he said, he later said, a few months later, that he decided to take the Philippines after asking God for guidance. And he said he got down on his knees and prayed to Almighty God for guidance. What do I do with the Philippines? And God told him to take the Philippines and to educate the Filipinos and uplift and civilize
种族主义的隐含动机。但他根本没有准备好给菲律宾人独立，尽管他们和古巴人一样，也在为独立而战。他说，难道我们要把它交给另一个帝国主义强国吗？他说，不，那太愚蠢了。我们不能这么做。我们不能就这么把它交给——我们是从西班牙手里夺过来的，现在总不能转手交给英国人或法国人吧。因此，这是一个极其艰难的决定，在政治上也极具极化效应。后来他说，几个月后他表示，自己在向上帝寻求指引后，决定接管菲律宾。他说自己曾跪下向全能的上帝祈求指引：我该拿菲律宾怎么办？上帝告诉他，去接管菲律宾，去教育菲律宾人，提升并文明化他们，
and Christianize them. And then historians have never believed that. They've always thought that was hogwash. But none of them have looked at who McKinley was. He was this incredibly devout evangelical Methodist who always, I mean, if you look in McKinley's writings, his diary and whatnot, every time he faced a difficult decision, he was praying to God for guidance for it. So it's not, you know, it's quite realistic that he did this as well for the Philippines. Historians have singled out that one phrase, Christianize, that he wanted to Christianize the Filipinos. And they say, silly McKinley, they were already Catholic. They don't need to be Christianized. But McKinley, of course, knew that they were Catholic already. What he meant, they were proper Christians. They weren't true Christians. They had to be made Protestants. And with that is education.
使他们基督教化。然而历史学家从来不相信这一点。他们一直认为这全都是无稽之谈。但他们当中没有人去研究过麦金莱究竟是个什么样的人。他是一个极其虔诚的福音派卫理公会教徒，每当他面临艰难抉择时——如果你翻看麦金莱的著作、日记之类的内容就会发现——他总是向上帝祈求指引。因此，他在菲律宾问题上也这么做，其实是非常真实的，并不让人意外。历史学家们单单挑出了那个词——“基督教化”，即他想要让菲律宾人基督教化。他们说，愚蠢的麦金莱，他们本来就是天主教徒啊，根本不需要被基督教化。但麦金莱当然知道他们已经是天主教徒了。他的意思是，他们不是正统的基督徒，他们不是真正的基督徒。他们必须被改造为新教徒。随之而来的就是教育。
There's a question here from Alfonso XIV, the pretender. Oh, I'm honored. Is the religious spirit in forming US wars any different from the evangelical component of 19th century British imperialism? And am I right that it's the annexation of the Philippines that prompts Kipling to take up the white man's burden? Exactly. It's that decision that McKinley was wrestling with and Kipling contributed. So Kipling writes that first. He's kind of encouraging the Americans to shoulder their responsibility as upholders of Anglo-Saxon Protestantism, basically. Yeah, take up the white man's burden. But then, of course, the poem is full of all the problems that are going to ensue.
这里有一个来自 претендент（王位觊觎者）阿方索十四世的问题。哦，我深感荣幸。美国战争中所蕴含的宗教精神，与19世纪英国帝国主义的福音派成分有什么不同吗？我说的对吗，正是对菲律宾的兼并促使吉卜林写下了《白人的负担》？完全正确。正是麦金莱当时在纠结的那个决定，促成了吉卜林的作品。所以吉卜林最早写下了那首诗。他某种程度上是在鼓励美国人承担起他们作为盎格鲁-撒克逊新教主义维护者的责任。是的，承担起白人的负担。但当然，这首诗也充满了随之而来的各种问题。
But Andrew, what you were saying a second ago raised a really interesting question I'm sure would appeal to tom because tom tom's basic tom's sort of modus operandi is to tell us how christian things are but also to point out how uncomfortable people are with acknowledging that so tom's constantly having kind of twitter battles with humanists do you think when we tell the story of america i mean people often you know you open the guardian or something and there's some great essay about American imperialism. Do we often miss the religious element to all this, do you think? Because historians are not comfortable talking. I mean, that's kind of your argument, isn't it, Tom? A lot of historians are not terribly comfortable talking about religion because they're not religious. They think we live in a post-religious age.
但是安德鲁，你刚才说的话引出了一个非常有趣的问题，这肯定会吸引汤姆，因为汤姆的行事风格——汤姆的一贯套路就是告诉我们事物有多么基督教化，同时也指出人们对于承认这一点是多么感到不自在。所以汤姆经常在推特上和人文主义者发生论战。你认为当我们讲述美国的历史时——我的意思是，人们经常，你知道的，你翻开《卫报》之类报纸，总能看到某篇关于美帝国主义的大作。你认为我们是不是经常忽略了这一切背后的宗教元素？因为历史学家们对谈论这个感到不自在。我的意思是，这正是你的论点，对吧，汤姆？许多历史学家非常不习惯谈论宗教，因为他们本身不信教。他们认为我们生活在一个后宗教时代。
Well, no, I would say that they are religious. The criticism of empire is itself bred of Christian assumptions. Of course, I mean, that's what you would. You know, that's the whole thing. Yeah. But Andrew, what do you think? Do you think people are not as, so you gave McKinley as an example. So the thing that people would, the assumption that people would jump to is that McKinley
嗯，不，我会说他们其实是有宗教性的。对帝国的批判本身就是孕育于基督教的假设之中的。当然，我的意思是，你肯定会这么说。你知道，整件事情就是这样。是的。但安德鲁，你怎么看？你认为人们是不是没有那么——所以你把麦金莱作为例子。人们会直接跳跃到的假设是，麦金莱
talking to God is merely a fig leaf for, you know, he wants markets. He's a cruel imperialist. But you don't think that at all, right? Well, I think it's, I just think that it's easy to sort of write religion out of that story, and just to assume that it's for material interest, that they're just looking for the China market, or they're just looking for strategic advantage against imperial rivals. But there's much more to it than that. because just the search for markets, just geopolitics, just sort of trying to find coaling stations for your Navy as you go across the Pacific to get to a place like China. All of those material, all of those material interests don't really explain how the U.S. decided to annex the Philippines and what they tried to do when they were there.
向上帝倾诉仅仅是一块遮羞布，（心底里）你知道的，他想要市场，他是个残忍的帝国主义者。但你完全不这么认为，对吗？嗯，我认为这，我只是觉得把宗教从那个故事中抹去太容易了，人们很容易想当然地认为这一切纯粹是为了物质利益，他们只是在寻找中国市场，或者只是在寻找对抗帝国竞争对手的战略优势。但事情远比这要复杂得多。因为仅仅是对市场的追逐，仅仅是地缘政治，仅仅是为了穿越南太平洋前往中国这样的地方而试图寻找运煤站——所有这些物质利益，所有这些物质诉求，并不能真正解释美国为什么决定兼并菲律宾，以及他们在那里时究竟试图做些什么。
And in changing Filipino society and in imposing certain values and spreading certain values. So like I said before, you know, putting religion back into that story, because it was always part of the story. And I think just as it's a basic historian's duty to sort of examine history on its own terms and not on our terms. But just by putting religion back into that story, it's more historically accurate. I don't want to use the word accurate, but it's more historically representative of what actually happened. But then it helps us really uncover their motives of why they did what they did and how they did what they did. It doesn't change if you take religion out. Yes, the U.S. still fights the Spanish-American War.
以及在改变菲律宾社会、强加某些价值观以及传播某些价值观的过程中。所以就像我之前说的，你知道，把宗教重新放回那个故事中，因为它本来就是故事的一部分。我认为，就像一个基本的历史学家有责任以历史事物本身的条件去审视历史，而不是用我们今天的条件去衡量一样。仅仅通过把宗教重新放回那个故事中，它就在历史上更具准确性。我不想用“准确”这个词，但它更能代表历史上实际发生的事情。而这反过来又真正有助于我们揭示他们动机——他们为什么做他们所做的事，以及他们是如何做那些事的。如果你抽掉宗教，事情并不会改变。是的，美西战争依然会爆发。
Yes, it probably still annexes the Philippines. But it does so in extremely different ways with different consequences. And I think it's really the historian's duty to acknowledge that and to get to it. imperialism that both britain and america are obviously this this this sense of protestantism of evangelical certitude um the sense that they have been entrusted by god with um with with a global mission but also at the same time the kind of nagging anxiety that that breeds about whether it's the right thing to do and obviously for the for brit British imperialism, abolitionism becomes a kind of crucial justification for the expansion of the British Empire into Africa and kind of vast swathes of the world. America has defined itself, its sense of its own virtue is predicated on the fact that it is anti-imperial, that it has rejected the Babylon of, you know, Georgian London. That must be a kind
是的，它可能依然会兼并菲律宾。但它这样做的方式会截然不同，带来的后果也大相径庭。我认为承认这一点并深入探究，确实是历史学家应尽的职责。英国和美国共同拥有的帝国主义——显然，这种新教精神、福音派的确信感，那种他们被上帝委以全球使命的使命感，但与此同时，这也伴随着一种挥之不去的焦虑，即这样做到底是不是正确的选择。当然，对于英国帝国主义而言，废奴主义成为了英国帝国主义向非洲以及世界大片地区扩张的一种关键正当理由。而美国一直以来对自身的定义、对其自身美德的感知，都是建立在它是反帝的这一基础之上的，即它拒绝了乔治王朝时期伦敦的“巴比伦”。对于美国基督徒来说，这一定是一个复杂的因素，当他们面对——
of complicating factor for American Christians when they face up to the, you know, they don't want to think that they're imperial. I mean, the British have no problem in saying, yes, we have a British empire. Americans right up to this day are very, very nervous about acknowledging that they've ever been an imperial power, whether that's in terms of, you know, the continental landmass of North America being an empire or the kind of expansion overseas into Philippines and, you know, or even, you know, it's kind of hegemony over Western Europe or Middle East or the Pacific today. And would you say that that's kind of bred of ultimately Christian?
他们不希望自己被看作是帝国主义者。我的意思是，英国人可以毫无问题地说：是的，我们拥有一个大英帝国。但直到今天，美国人对于承认自己曾经或现在是一个帝国主义强国，依然感到非常非常紧张，无论是就北美大陆本土是一座帝国而言，还是就海外向菲律宾等地扩张而言，甚至是对今天西欧、中东或太平洋地区的霸权而言。你会不会说，这种心态最终也是孕育自基督教的？
I mean, it reflects kind of Christian assumptions, moral assumptions. I think it has, I think it reflects a lot of Christian assumptions. I think it reflects Protestant values, even if they're not necessarily very scripturally coherent, but a certain Protestant ethos that goes back to your, how we began this podcast and that idea that the United States, or that this is long, it's, that's a historical talking about the United States or that this is long, that's a historical talking about the United States in the 17th century, but that the American identity was forged through this self-conceit that they're a city on a hill and that the eyes of the world are upon them through to manifest destiny, through to imperialism. I mean, Americans, you're absolutely right, Tom. Americans deny that they've ever had an empire. It's a commonplace in American political rhetoric today to say, and it has been for a long time, to say that America has never had an empire and it never wants to be an empire, that they were arguing over whether they should have an empire. And imperialists called themselves imperialists and anti-imperialists called themselves anti-imperialists and had this huge, huge argument in 1899, 1900.
我的意思是，它反映了一种基督教假设，一种道德假设。我认为它确实包含，我认为它反映了大量的基督教假设。我认为它反映了新教的价值观，即使它们在经文上未必非常连贯一致，但它包含了一种特定新教的精神气质，可以追溯到我们这期播客的开头，以及那种认为美国——或者说这种长久以来的历史探讨，探讨美国或17世纪的美国，但无论如何，美国的身份认同是通过这样一种自负塑造起来的：他们是“山巅之城”，世界的目光都聚焦在他们身上，从昭昭天命（Manifest Destiny）一直延续到帝国主义。我的意思是，美国人，汤姆，你完全说得对。美国人否认他们曾拥有过帝国。在今天的美国政治修辞中，这是一种司空见惯的说法，而且长久以来一直如此，即美国从来没有过帝国，也永远不想成为一个帝国——尽管当年他们曾为是否应该拥有一个帝国而争论不休。帝国主义者自称为帝国主义者，反帝国主义者自称为反帝国主义者，双方在1899年、1900年爆发了规模宏大的激烈争论。
And a lot of those arguments, not all of them. So people who took part in this debate, people like Mark Twain, who were very critical of Christianity, very critical of missionaries, and also very anti imperialist. People like Mark Twain did not necessarily, well, they didn't at all use religious values or religious rhetoric. But a lot of people did at the time, including a lot of policymakers, including the President of the United States himself, William McKinley, and then to a much different extent, his successor, Theodore Roosevelt. So that was acknowledged at the time. It did play out. But then the Americans take over the Philippines. They fight this incredibly brutal war to suppress the Filipino insurgency because the Filipinos say, hang on, we just fought. We were your allies against the Spanish. Now you're going to dominate us. We don't like that. So there was this incredibly
而许多这样的争论——并非全部。因此，那些参与这场辩论的人，比如马克·吐温这样对基督教极度批判、对传教士极度批判、同时也极度反帝的人。像马克·吐温这样的人并不一定——嗯，他们完全没有使用宗教价值观或宗教修辞。但在当时，许多其他人确实使用了，其中包括许多政策制定者，包括美国总统本人威廉·麦金莱，以及后来的西奥多·罗斯福（虽然程度大不相同）。因此，这一点在当时是得到了承认的，它确实发挥了作用。但随后美国接管了菲律宾。他们打了一场极其残酷的战争来镇压菲律宾的叛乱，因为菲律宾人说：“等等，我们刚刚打过仗。我们是你们对抗西班牙的盟友。现在你们要统治我们了。我们不喜欢这样。”因此爆发了这场极其残酷的战争。
brutal war. And then the united states you know suppresses the insurgency the philippines is an american colony within 10 years the americans do not have that british commitment to making the empire work that you were talking about that gladstone spirit if we call it if we if we're to give it a name and um they just kind of forget the empire they want to forget the empire they just want to completely the empire. They just want to completely leave it behind. Why do they, as it were, so Kipling has urged them to take up the white man's burden. And to some extent, they have taken it up. They did.
然后美国，你知道的，镇压了叛乱，菲律宾成了美国的殖民地。但在10年之内，美国人并没有表现出你刚才提到的那种英国人让帝国运转起来的坚定承诺——如果我们给它起个名字的话，也就是格莱斯顿精神——他们只是把帝国给忘了，他们想要忘记帝国，只想把帝国彻底抛在脑后。为什么他们会——就像吉卜林敦促他们承担起“白人的负担”一样，在某种程度上，他们确实承担了。他们确实做到了。
Oh, absolutely. Then they put it down again. Right? I mean, why are they embarrassed? Why do they become embarrassed by empire? So the United States in the mid-20th century is absolutely not calling itself an empire. And as you said yourself, no American politician now would say, we had an empire, or indeed, we are an empire. Why do they back away from that idea, the imperialist ideal, if you like?
哦，当然。然后他们又把它放下了，对吧？我的意思是，他们为什么会感到尴尬？为什么他们会对帝国感到难堪？因此，20世纪中叶的美国绝对不称自己为帝国。正如你自己所说的那样，如今没有任何一个美国政客会说“我们曾拥有一个帝国”，或者“我们是一个帝国”。他们为什么要从这种理念——如果你愿意的话，即帝国主义理想——中退缩呢？
I mean, because that predates the collapse of the European empires, doesn't it? They're backing away. Yeah, absolutely. At first, so you said, why do they put it down? But that implies that it's a conscious decision to put it down. I think it's just, Americans just don't care. There aren't a lot of, there are no American settlers
我的意思是，这在欧洲帝国崩溃之前就已经发生了，不是吗？他们在往回退缩。是的，完全如此。起初，你刚才说“为什么他们把它放下？”，但这暗示这是一种有意识决定将它放下。我认为这只是美国人根本不在乎。并没有大量的美洲定居者
who go to places like the Philippines. It's not like Britain at all. There are very few Americans who even want, like government officials or military officials who want to be posted there. It becomes a sideshow. And so it's a process of forgetting, as opposed to a conscious decision to put down. And then American foreign policy, I mean, there's not really anywhere else in the world to take, right, to seize. And the unhappy experience of
前往菲律宾之类的地方。这和英国完全不同。甚至很少有美国人——无论是政府官员还是军事官员——愿意被派驻到那里。它变成了一个边缘事件。所以这是一个遗忘的过程，而不是一个有意识决定放下的决定。随后美国的外交政策——我的意思是，世界上其实也没有其他地方可供占领或夺取了。而且
the Philippines means that the US isn't looking to take anywhere over anyway. And then what defines US foreign policy after that? I mean, it fights two world wars and a Cold War against empires, against different types of empire, Nazi empire, Japanese empire, Soviet empire. You know, Reagan in 1983 calls the Soviets the evil empire. It becomes embedded in American foreign policy that not only are they not imperial, but their enemies, whether they're on the far left in communism or the far right in Nazism or somewhere vaguely in the middle,
菲律宾的不愉快经历意味着美国无论如何也不想再四处占领地方了。那么，在那之后是什么定义了美国的外交政策呢？我的意思是，它打赢了两场世界大战，并进行了一场反对帝国的冷战——反对不同类型的帝国：纳粹帝国、日本帝国、苏联帝国。里根在1983年将苏联称为“邪恶帝国”。这已经深深植根于美国的对外政策中：不仅他们自己不是帝国，而且他们的敌人——无论是极左的共产主义、极右的纳粹主义，还是介于两者之间某个模糊地带的势力，
maybe towards the Nazis in Japanese imperialism, that the enemy is empire. And so that becomes a dominating, that's not necessarily a religious idea, but it becomes very, very powerful. But also, I mean, it's an inheritance from the founding
也许偏向纳粹和日本帝国主义——他们的敌人就是帝国。因此，这成了一种主导力量，虽然这不一定是一个宗教观念，但它变得极其强大。而且，这也是从美国的建国
of the United States, which was 40 years ago. Oh, absolutely. Of course. Yeah, exactly. Yeah. And Americans, they return to that all the time. Yeah, yeah. Absolutely fascinating stuff, as ever, with Professor Andrew Preston. And we're going to come back tomorrow, moving to the 20th century, starting with the First World War, all the way up to the post 9-11 world, and then Trump, the present day, all that malararkey so we will see you then goodbye thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early access ad free listening access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com.
传统中继承下来的，而建国已经是40年前的事了。哦，当然。这是当然的。是的，完全如此。是的。正如安德鲁·普雷斯顿教授一如既往地带给我们绝对精彩的内容。我们明天会回归，将时间推移到20世纪，从第一次世界大战开始，一直讲到“9·11”后的世界，再到特朗普以及当下的现实，所有这些乱七八糟的事情。所以我们到时见，再见！感谢收听《历史的其余部分》（The Rest is History）。想要获取独家单集、提前收听、无广告收听权限以及我们的聊天社区权限，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。
That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes,
网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的其余部分》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及海量的娱乐圈八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们将拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家单集，
and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及提前购买现场演出门票的权限，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。